بعد عامين من حضر ترامب من منصه تويتر
يعود الموقع بمالك جديد يسمح لترامب
بتغريد مجددا وخلال دقائق تويتر الغى حظر
الملف الشخصي للرئيس السابق على المنصه
ولكن الواقع يخالف التوقعات فقد قالت
ترامب انه لا يرى اي سبب للعوده الى تويتر
والسبب كما عزاء بان تويتر يعاني من
مشكلات كثيره ولا يصدق ذاهبا الى ابعد من
ذلك بالقول ان حسابات المنصه معظمها مزيفه
تصريحات ترامب هذه تاتي بعد ان استفتاء
مالك من الصائم ماسك جمهوره تويتر في عوده
ترامب الاستفتاء شارك به اكثر من 15 مليون
مستخدم ما يؤكده دعم الملايين لطرح وعوده
التمر حيث وصلت نسبه الدعم اكثر من واحد
55% ليحدد بذلك الج بقاء ترامب ويعلنها
ماسك ترامب نفسه تفاعل مع الاستفتاء
بطريقه اخرى فقد قال للمستخدمين انتم
صوتتم بايجابيه ولكن لا تقلقوا لن اذهب
الى مكان بعيد وهنا تبدو المفارقه ان
ترامب تحدث عن منصاته سوشيال توت واصفا
اياها بالمميزه وهي المنصه التي اطلقها
بعد حضره من تويتر